what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
player stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion man
you more like man me I don't dress to
impress
I dress to kagan press he tells him more
about yourself Kevin the Branagh we
remember that amazing goal I scored it
to win the puskás neither do I he's
coming he's coming you guys our great
maestro arrives how are you terrible I
could use a massage my centre back is
killing me
hello Red Devils I apologize for being
late I lost the dressing room I mean I
lost my way to the dressing room it's
the media the media want to say things
are bad here they say my players are sad
they are wrong and so to prove this I am
forcing all the players to come to my
party tonight
[Music]
I've gathered you all here to remind you
that just because you are not good it
doesn't mean we can't have a good time
now enjoy your mandatory meal
what's the matter look not enough
cholesterol is for you what is this this
looks like crap excuse me more but I
have a bigger role I don't get higher
McGwire you don't get more food
alright let's party Alexis play the play
coach I don't really want to do this
[Applause]
[Music]
never list additional skills on your CV
hello oh hey David Moyes is here goodbye
he's gone
oh man is smoke born anywhere Akane
tells about how much he misses his wife
okay who wants to play a game you guys
want to play a game so the object of
these games is you try to score once and
then after that you sit back and wait
for time to run out it's the best way to
waste 90 minutes Oh a special one that
means I get to throw a player under the
bus let's see so many choices how about
don't want to play this anymore you
won't play where I say you play but Paul
I'm kidding I only say this because
you're my favorite this game is not fun
games are not supposed to be fun they
are supposed to be hard and tedious what
is this garbage Paul can we go coach
you're no problem in your long term evil
hey what are you doing here Simon told
me that this belt in needed new energy
you were not invited go away
[Music]